hi I'm John Warner game director for
anthem here is the world premiere of
anthems gameplay
Hey
[Music]
freelancer Braxley
listen trouble big trouble what did you
do mistake I hired some people they
weren't freelancers I know they said
they could handle it and the price was
right
I thought maybe unbelievable you're
right it was stupid I'm sorry but
they're still out there somewhere if you
just bring them back anything you need
in the world of anthem you and your
friends are freelancers the heroes who
leave the safety of the walls of port
Tarsus to explore the unknown and
protect humanity
let's join two players as they head out
on an expedition you ready to go
just grab us with supplies just already
what are you gonna use today ourselves
go with the Colossus
I'm gonna use my ranger try out some new
upgrades
[Music]
every player will own an array of
exosuits we call javelins these suits
give players superhuman capabilities and
are heavily customizable so they look
and play how you want looking good
nice you got a mortar equipped yeah I
got on the weekend you lead the way
[Music]
this is a vast open world you explore
with your friends
each javelin exosuit has its own unique
play style the Ranger is balanced in all
purpose while the Colossus is a tanking
powerhouse let's see what's up here
the world of anthem is hostile and
threats can come from any direction
dynamic world was unexpected it's around
every corner yeah he seems like a
problem for another day
weirdest apart from the heavy / low you
flank
hang in there almost there
have you been in there yet haven't I
wish to do that later with Kim you can
use the XP hello treasure
I think we got some action man
we're under attack anyone in the area
we're under attack I think that's part
of prac situation
you can equip your javelin exosuit with
gear that brings devastating power to
combat
oh there are a lot of scars down there
all the scars have a heavy have time to
use that mortar covering fire there's a
bunch more coming in okay I'll get this
round
oh come on be something good yeah
Jerry's rad oh nice
large-scale world events like Schafer
storms a dynamic and pull you off the
beaten path with the promise of new
stories to discover Oh shiver storming
coming okay
actually let's get some more people hold
on a second hey guys what's up hey
what's happening right behind you
Oh
this storm is getting crazy
[Music]
what are we supposed to do fly into it
alright let's do this
see on the other side
our story is out there
[Applause]